good afternoon and welcome back I'm sure
that the afternoon panels are going to
be as interesting and as useful as those
we held in the morning Henry Kissinger
once said that Israel does not have
foreign policy only domestic politics
this is probably true also for many
countries and maybe even the United
States in theory the issue of domestic
politics and foreign policy is known as
the two-level game which means that
politicians and policymakers when they
formulate foreign policy they have they
have on the one hand to consider
diplomacy and national interests and on
the other hand they have also to
consider at the same time a public
opinion and domestic possible domestic
responses to what they want to achieve
so domestic politics constrain the
number and scope of choices policymakers
consider and therefore we thought that
it's very important to have a whole
piano about domestic politics and
foreign policy we have distinguished
scholars here from different places and
perspectives and we will discuss this
afternoon domestic politics and foreign
policy American foreign policies vary
foreign policy may be also Arab foreign
policy our first speaker is Professor sy
Feldman who is director of the crown
center for Middle East Studies at
Brandeis University first apartment
please
also just to correct something you see
in your program in indeed I am from
brandons University and not from
bar-ilan University for good or bad well
actually this is a difficult session
because if you notice if any of you who
were here in the first two sessions know
that everything that we were discussed
was about domestic politics so we're
just going to I guess improve upon that
in the indeed just before the break I
wasn't sure what's left was to to to
talk about I'm going to maybe just
correct some impressions that I think
need to be corrected about the
discussion of some of the issues until
now more or less about where Israel or
mayor something about the impression
that you could have got about Israelis
views on this I think that in Israel
there is a greater appreciation that may
have been reflected from the first two
sessions that these are difficult issues
the issues that we're dealing with not
issues that have very easy answers to
and the other thing is that i would like
to plead with my friends everywhere
including from my friends from Israel to
try to avoid confusing analysis with
prescriptions when you focus on
prescriptions it's very easy for people
to misconstrue what you're saying as
analysis that is serving the preferred
prescriptions I have to say that I was
also personally I want to make two
personal comments before I get to my
positive point if they will be
considered by interview to be positive
the first is that we Israelis
i am from brandeis university but I
still carry only an israeli passport
today I think that we as raleys have to
be very very careful and very modest
before we prescribe to Americans where
they should go to war over because these
are American lives at stake and we have
to be very very careful in count to 10
before we do that lest Israel provide
and Israelis provide more footnotes to
some of Israel's detractors in this
country secondly on the substantive I
think we need to be very careful against
of labeling people such as irresponsible
academics that believe in containment I
am an academic I like to see myself with
think of myself as responsible and I
believe in containment I am a strong
believer in deterrence and deterrence is
one type of containment what I the main
point I'd like to make about the
domestic side of all of this is that
there is a rich Israeli internal debate
on a very sophisticated debate on almost
all the issues that were discussed in
the first two sessions there is no
Israeli view of these issues there are
multiple Israeli views on these issues
and this is why it's very also difficult
and important to avoid talking about any
of these issues with certainty I think
that most people at the top of the
Israeli Defense community are too
careful to refer to these with any kind
of certainty and I found that the gap
between or the fact there was some gap
between in my view between the
music of the conversation the certainty
that we saw here given the fact that six
weeks or eight weeks before the events
began to unfold in Tunisia not a single
person had saw this coming and now all
of the sudden were all certain about
where this will go in Israel on the
Palestinian issue there is a monumental
debate and the debate is taking place at
the top echelon as well as you know that
Israeli defense minister has warned in a
number of different places including in
this city not too long ago I think maybe
a week ago of a tsunami a political
tsunami that Israel might experience
come September when the two year are in
a state institution building project of
Salam Fayyad will expire and the
Palestinians will towards that date and
probably after that they launch a major
campaign the campaign in the
Palestinians view which may be imani
will refer to will try to limit itself
to D legitimizing occupation I tell my
Palestinian colleagues that's not how
it's going to end it's going to slip
very very quickly to delegitimize Israel
and that involves huge risks in my view
for both sides but but anyway there this
is this does not yield two very simple
analysis on Syria there are there is a
huge debate at the top of the israeli
defense community there are of course
the price of a deal or the cost of a
deal with syria is crystal clear whether
the price is worth paying is a subject
of huge debate and there are those and
they is a very valid point of view to
take they'd say we've looked at this and
we decided the cost is too high but to
completely dismiss the counter arguments
that say is taking syria out of the
equation
out of the tehran damascus hezbollah
hamas axis is not going to significantly
change the strategic map in the Middle
East that I think is a point of view
that needs to be taken seriously on Iran
we heard one side of the internal
Israeli debate yes there is a view a
strong view that says in its most
extreme form an Iranian nuclear bomb is
Nazi Germany in the 30s with nuclear
weapons this has certainly been the
rhetoric of Israeli Prime Minister
Netanyahu until he became prime minister
two years ago he is not repeated those
kinds of references more recently there
is of course a second cap that says
Israel is a strong country it's a
regional power and it has a response to
every contingency that is certainly the
language that defense minister Bach has
used on more than one occasion and what
the debate the Israeli internal debate
really boils down to is the question of
whether it is possible to deter a
nuclear Iran and as it is tempting to
think that it was not would not be
possible because of certain undeniable
dimensions or aspects of especially the
present president of Iran let me also
point out to all of us that if indeed
Israel cannot deter a nuclear Iran there
is a really big problem with our own
narrative which I by the way I'm a
strong believer and adherent to about
Israel's need to develop a nuclear
option if Ben Gurion did not believe
that it would not be possible to deter a
faraway adversary like Iran then
what exactly is the rationale for having
invested six decades in a project and as
I said I'm on this one on the side of
the people that supported and continue
to support the project it certainly was
not meant to deter Palestinian
terrorists you don't exactly deter
Palestinian terrorists with nuclear
bombs it's also more problematic to
deter proximate neighbors because of the
physical properties of nuclear of
nuclear weapons so if nuclear deterrence
is credible against anyone it's actually
credible more credible against the more
distant adversaries so the problem is
that you can't argue both sides of the
argument at the same time and I think
that equal caution should be exercised
when we deal with the new the change the
dramatic changes in the region that we
saw in the last few months it is
tempting of course and people get paid
for it in the Israeli intelligence
community to look only at the risks that
these changes produce for Israel and
they produce risks there is no question
about it and threat but do they produce
only threats do they not also produce
some opportunities there is a new and I
say a new middle class in Egypt that
even was not seen by some of our
Egyptian colleagues until recently there
is more tied to Western technology
Western values at least some of them is
there no opportunity there in Syria
there are huge risks for Israel that got
accustomed to a stable system of
deterrence with Syria for at least 35
years but would a sunni-led Syria be
only risks and not opportunities would
it not be easier with some creative
diplomacy and risk taking on Israel side
would it not be easier
to take a sunni-led Syria out of the
axis out of the tehran damascus
Hizballah axis so that is not again to
make the opposite point which is that
all the news for Israel in these changes
are dandy but it would be very to be a
grave mistake to focus and to be to be
almost captivated by only the risks and
threats that are associated with these
changes and I would just like to close
by a comment on what my previous
comments should tell you about the
Israeli domestic scene I think there is
a good news and there's bad news the
good news is that Israel is like America
everything is debated everything is
debated and just as America faces real
dilemmas in Iraq and Afghanistan and
Libya let alone other issues
particularly domestic ones all of the
issues regarding which you heard some
certainties about in the first two
sessions are hotly debated in Israel
just as they would have been hotly
debated in America the bad news is that
this period is a period of
uncharacteristic paralysis in the top
echelons of the Israeli system we have
had debates on policy since the state
was established in 1948 but these
debates now are at the top echelon the
pinnacle of the system most israeli
foreign and defense affairs strategic
decisions are taken by the so-called
septet the seven ministers that
netanyahu convenes which of course by
itself is a problematic cystal concept
because it has the septet has no
statutory is not a statutory body and
the next time that we find ourselves in
a 2006 situation and there will be an a
commission of inquiry the fur
issue that they will have to take up is
how come the most important decisions
have been taken in the last two years by
a body that has no statutory standing
but the point is that within the sub
debt all of these issues within the
subtest are are debated and for the past
two years it's been nearly impossible to
reach any decision on already finished
ah any decision on on on these issues
and and therefore unfortunately Israel
remains in limbo on almost all of these
issues and have remained in limbo for
the past two years thank you thank you
very much a professor Feldman our next
speaker is M&E Jamal who is an associate
professor of politics at Princeton
University please thank you so much it's
a real pleasure to be here today I was
asked to talk about public opinion the
Middle East and perhaps even the the
American Muslim community and how that
might impact ongoing debates about the
arab-israeli conflict regional
developments and perhaps democratization
in the region more broadly I would like
to take this opportunity to highlight
and maybe perhaps showcase some of the
findings of my new book which is under
contract and I'm actually spending every
minute of the day where I'm not talking
or teaching or working trying to get
that book back to the publishers because
of the events in the region and the
timeliness of the argument so the the
and and this directly links up to the
arab-israeli conflict as well so the
title of the book is a more or less it
deals with this issue of democracy
democratization democratic developments
in the region it really takes on a
public opinion perspective of the Arab
region and it basically argues that for
the longest period of time when we've
looked at regional developments when
we've looked at us bilateral relations
with Arab states or we've looked at
Israeli bilateral relations with the
night
with Arab states that's exactly what
they've been bilateral state-to-state
negotiations or treaties or agreements
where you've had states that are
authoritarian that don't represent the
desires or interest or viewpoints of
their citizens so hence we've basically
had policymakers at the state level
engaging and claiming to be representing
their citizens will not necessarily
engaging their own citizens I mean the
channels of as you all know the channels
of accountability of deliberation of
democratic kind of participation have
not been free and fair citizens have not
been able to hold their leaders
accountable have not been able to
participate in any meaningful way in
political life in the Arab region I'm
generalizing but more or less this is a
takeaway point so immediately of course
when you have events like Egypt and
Tunisia unfold the big question that
emerges is well where is the Arab pulse
where is Arab public opinion what will
this mean for the ongoing peace treaty
with Israel for example between Egypt
and Israel what does this mean for the
arab-israeli conflict what does this
mean for the future of democratization
in the region and hence now as we
monitor the developments of what's
happening in Egypt when elections will
be held how they will be held what
nature or how democratic will those
elections be the key question that we're
asking ourselves is what role will the
Muslim Brotherhood play and will the
Muslim Brotherhood honor pre existing
treaties and treaties and agreements
that the earlier regime had already
struck and these are important debates
because I argue in the book not only are
they important for regional development
and regional stability and Shia alluded
to this but they're also important for
internal negotiations about democracy
right so now there it's not fair to
assume that the Egyptian population in
its entirety is anti-israel or anti
American horse or doesn't stand to
benefit from stronger ties with the
United States these are polarized
societies there are those that basically
do link
economic interests their economic
well-being the future of their countries
the national well-being of their
societies if you may to stronger ties to
the United States to stronger ties to
Europe to even stronger ties to Israel
and they acknowledge that and they will
say that however there are also segments
of the society that for so long have
been ignored by their regimes for so
long have been impoverished by really
repressive political and economic
policies that they don't believe that
they have much to stand or benefit from
for example maintaining strong ties to
the United States so the question before
us then is and we really don't know
because for the longest time well I mean
I guess the big question is well where
does where does Egyptian society stand
and we really don't know that because
for the longest period of time Egypt are
one of our closest allies in the region
would not allow us even to conduct a
public opinion survey in Egypt right for
over a decade we have tried to basically
test the pulse of the Egyptian
population and year in and year out they
have kicked us out of the country and
allowed us to ask basic questions like
your age education basic demographics
but you could not happen to public
opinion and one of the things that they
were worried about the most was asking
questions these these questions that
that are the theme of this conference
which is what are you what are your
perspectives on the United States what
are your perspectives on the treaty with
Israel and the degree of support for the
Muslim Brotherhood excuse me has always
been very worrisome to the regime so
what what emerges then in the Arab world
is that in addition to our models of
democratization in addition to the
variables that we have used to examine
the democratic health or the the the the
probability of democratic development in
these societies and those we've often
focused at these domestic level factors
right how educated is the population how
culturally in tuned is that are these
populations to Western values to Western
civilization's how Islamic are these
countries because we basically still buy
into the argument that Islam and
democracy are incompatible where are the
economic preconditions on the ground for
these societies the
are all domestic level models of
democratization but there's another
layer that I argue that is very
important is that citizens themselves
and we saw this in Palestine in 2006 we
see this in Egypt today we see this in
Morocco people are also asking basically
saying look at the the Middle East the
Arab world does not exist in a vacuum
and a lot of these states do depend on
stronger access to Western countries for
their own strategic benefit and these
are negotiations happening at the
societal level therefore they deem it in
their own interest also not to elect not
to bring to power groups that may not
represent the interest or that the
well-being of their countries and my
favorite anecdote and shy and I have
talked about this earlier is to look at
even the Palestinian elections in 2006
yes those elections brought Hamas to
power there we had support for democracy
at seventy-eight percent when we asked
Palestinians in the West Bank and Gaza
do you support democracy do you support
free and fair elections seventy-eight
percent of the Palestinian population
said yes they do right after the Hamas
election immediately after the Hamas
election when it was clear that Hamas
had basically won the majority of seats
still 78% supported democracy however
after months and months of sanctions
that level of support for democracy
falls drastically in the three to six
months after after the sanctions were
imposed now well about six months after
after the sanctions about forty percent
supported democracy so that leads you to
believe that there are segments within
the population but did not wish to steer
the Palestinian economy the Palestinian
Society the Palestinian political entity
if you may towards this idea of being at
war with Israel or placing their
countries in a position where they were
going to be suffering sanctions now
these are debates that are happening in
other parts of the Arab world so it's
very important when we think about the
future of democracy and democratization
and debates about democratization to
know that the Arab public opinion is not
a monolithic construct there's a lot of
variation
in within States there's a lot of debate
going on within States and so then the
question that we have to ask ourselves
what explains the variation why is it
that under some conditions or
circumstances populations swing all the
way and become far more anti-american
and then at other junctures in time
they're far more friendlier to the
United States and again these debates
structure debates about democratization
and the Democratic regime in power
you're not going to vote for an
anti-american opposition movement if you
feel that you're going to stand to
benefit from stronger ties the United
States and here is where we cannot
ignore them one of the biggest problems
that the United States has faced in the
region in terms of its own credibility I
mean in addition the United States faces
a lot of problems in the region in terms
of restoring its own credibility there's
the issue of supporting authoritarian
regimes and the history of supporting
these regimes right the most repressive
regimes in the country are the US this
is strongest allies oil is a big factor
here too is also the ongoing
arab-israeli conflict when the u.s. is
seen is not being able to deliver on
that conflict or for example when Obama
comes into office and basically make
settlements his platform and then has
not been able to move the settlement
issue further he loses credibility in
the region and this also leads to
increases in anti-americanism and when
you have increases in anti-americanism
it does not vote for democratization
debates because the anti-americanism
freeze into the hands of groups that
threaten us ties or ties to the United
States and now they're basically you
know it might be looking at this Iran
Syria Hezbollah Hamas Nexus as a source
of empowerment or an alternative to us
to US influence in the region so the
argument is now what what's happens with
the revolutions is that to think that
public opinion matters that the type of
regimes that will now emerged is going
to be reflective of public opinion means
that we have to start rethinking and I'm
not in the business of prescribing
either but
if I'm going to say anything it means
that then the actions of the United
States and how they they are digested
and how they are processed in the region
are going to be all the more important
in shaping the future democratization
debates in the region if anything
increases in anti-americanism are not
conducive to demcrata cratic regimes
and it's not fair to assume that all
democratic regimes that are going to be
reflecting and basically are going to be
represented representative of their
people are going to be anti-israel or
anti the US there are great variations
within these societies and I think
looking forward the task is going to be
basically how you might expand on those
pockets but are not necessarily out in
the streets carrying American flags and
professing love and commitment to the
United States but nevertheless they
understand that jeopardizing ties to the
United States or with Israel by default
is not in the interest of their
countries and it's not through military
force right you know if we if we learn
anything from the history of the Arab
world militarization increasing
militarization has only hardened and
increased anti-americanism in ways that
have not been conducive to us geo
strategic priorities in the region and
so basically if you're going to deal
with this in terms of negotiations or at
least in terms of diplomacy it's it's
about time in terms of really thinking
about the arab-israeli conflict and
resolving the arab-israeli conflict not
only so that there's a two-state
solution that reflects the security
interest of both Palestinians and
Israelis but also removes that issue off
the table so that so that opposition
movements cannot cano longer use that as
a means of mobilizing people on an
anti-israel anti-us platform in the
region thank you very much
thank you very much of a sama the third
speaker is smaller center he is a
professor of political science at
bar-ilan University a former immediate
Dean of Social Sciences and a senior
research associate at the better center
Center thank you what I learned is that
it in 12 minutes you can basically make
maybe half of an argument so try to
concentrate on one argument only it is
now become the received wisdom to argue
that in the Middle East especially in
Israel foreign policy is captured is the
prisoner of domestic facts of domestic
politics and as a ton said the Kissinger
famous phrase Israel does not have a
foreign policy has only domestic it is
now in Israel or also abroad very
fashionable to blame the impasse in the
peace process on domestic factors on
lieberman on charts and Netanyahu is the
prisoner of his partners in the
coalition I would like to argue the
opposite in dom going against my
academic career my whole column currency
since my dissertation went dissertation
was on on Vietnam and Korea on the
domestic factors I always concentrate on
domestic policies in foreign policy
however and I'm going to argue that when
it comes to major decisions to crucial
decisions Israeli Prime Minister's
always knew how to stand up and make
those decision the question is whether
they'll have such a proposal such a
situation in front of them soon
and I base it very briefly on three and
I think on the three most important
decisions in the Israeli history since
establishment of the state and if you
think about it even the Declaration of
Independence yes went against domestic
politics because I don't know how many
people know that mangalyaan did not have
a domestic support for his decision for
declaration of dependence there was no
consensus most of his parties including
the national religious party which is
that they considered the most hawkish
element was against Declaration of
Independence at this juncture however
let's look at the scene most important
decisions and I'm going to go of course
going to go very briefly and then
describe them the first one I think was
what we call an hourish are gone the
decision of our international
orientation in the early immediately
after establishment of the state is the
decided is going to be known aligned was
like this between 48 and 1950 was the
first country in the world to start the
non alignment group and despite the
domestic structure and I'm going to say
it in one sentence the domestic
structure was there were 63 members out
of hunt when the Knesset member 63 who
were Social Democrats Marxist or a or
beyond that yes the 63 members if you
take my palm was in the second party in
power and nevertheless ben-gurion
decided he's going to go with the West
primarily because he made the
calculations international calculation
he made also calculation about him and
he said it openly there were three
million Jews in Soviet Union who did not
have any influence there were six
million in the United States I have a
responsibility towards the Jews but my
international situation forces me and
that's why Israel water than the career
decisions together with the United
States
against the Soviet Union and by 1955 and
then this is research a basin on
research Israel was ready belonging
totally to the west even though the West
didn't know it wasn't too excited to
accept them but that's what our
orientation was and in only after 67 we
were formally accepted on to be more
correct in 64 was the first a visit
formal visit of an israeli prime
minister to Washington and was not been
going on but rather ash cold the second
most important decision was icing in
this resistor and I think everybody
would agree was of course the pieces
Egypt the second here again begging was
standing with a domestic everybody knows
what were his use yes he's standing with
a coalition that supported a hawkish
line and when the opportunity came and
there was a chance of making peace with
Egypt he did and the funny thing is or
the ironic thing was that many on the
Labour Party yes we're against the PISA
voted against because they said it's
against our legacy to remove settlements
yes wherever Jews settled they should
never be removed and many in the Labour
Party voted against him in the third
most important of course as I see it and
we getting closer to where we are now
was Oslo 1993 mmm Israel at least that's
how I see it 1992 was probably at one of
its most impor important predicaments in
history Israel 1992
I cannot think any point in our history
where we were as strong as we were in
1992 think about it the Intifada the
First Intifada was was winding down the
eastern front after operation desert
storm collapse there was no Iraq any
more on our Eastern Front Soviet Union
the big supporter of their world
collapsed and we were in the process of
absorbing 1 million Russian Jews coming
with most advanced education I once made
the calculations that probably Soviet
Union by giving us a 1 million Jews gave
us more support in 10 financial support
than the United States gave us all over
they used with billions of dollars
because you know what it is to accept a
bill a million Soviet Jews doctors and
so on and this came to us for free so in
1992 we were probably the most strongest
positions that we could imagine about
Neverland nevertheless Prime Minister
chakra been decided to be called an hour
gone prudence in victory he will go for
peace and he took the gamble which I
know I mean I know if I friend the shy
to detect many of the barrel on people
but I can assure you that the 1993 a
thriving bar and I and many of us we
were all for the Oslo gamble and he took
it he didn't have to take it because
domestically he had the labor was very
strong mr. abid was voted as mr.
security and that's what the reason why
he was awarded in he nevertheless took
it and I can say that so far not much
came out of that if you go to the
extreme I can say
that mr. David barackman the test was in
Camp David 2000 where Barack gave an
offer to mr. or the fact that I think
went against any domestic support I
don't think anybody knew you would agree
to it that there wouldn't be much
support for that but Barack offered
including the division of the of the old
city yes of the old city of jerusalem
and we know where this ended so if I
conclude I would say that if I look look
just at these three decisions do you
think I most important if I'm waiting
now for a fourth situation I'm sure
given these sleeper documents should
pursue a serious proposal coming from
the Arab side I think any prime minister
okay would do everything against public
opinion against domestic politics and
accept it otherwise he will not be able
to stay because I think that if I can't
say anything about Israeli public
opinion if there will be a serious peace
proposal no Prime Minister will be able
to ignore it well I'm afraid and this is
in conclusion I'm afraid that I don't
see something like this in the offering
let me just say that another thing and
that has to do also with the American
foreign policy I just everything now
earned david miller as a book about very
good title the match to promised land
and and he himself after whole chapter
where he dedicates about 60 70 pages
when he dedicates the domestic politics
in the United States yes Kim's he writes
my friend and colleague Dennis rose with
whom I work closely where wrote an
800-page account of US policy and the
peace process without discussing a peck
or domestic
political pressures and then he goes on
and he writes I can't remember a single
decision of consequence American Prince
passes advises made or one we didn't
that was directly tied to some lobby is
called letter or pressure tactics so in
conclusion in conclusion I would say
that despite the fact that we has
political scientists and we and we are
doing the right thing we analyze
domestic politics domestic politics is
important however if it comes to major
decision strategic decisions historic
decisions here i would say Israeli Prime
Minister's always took the chance and
gambled twice we did the right away I
think till today I'm happy with it we
Ben Gurion decided to go with the west
and not the Soviet Union I'm happy that
we did the agreement with Egypt where's
the Palestinians about also i still have
my doubts thank you thank you very much
professor sander and the last speaker on
this piano is Professor Robert Shapiro
with the professor political science
here at Columbia University former chair
of the Department of Political Science
he also served as acting director of
Columbia's institute for social and
economic research and policy professor
Shapiro please thank you
I'm going to focus on the politics of
American public opinion and the Middle
East first I want to say since I teach
nothing but quantitative methods and
statistics courses it's a it's a
pleasure to be able to talk about
something of importance in substance not
that teaching statistics is not an
important when dick bets invited me to
participate I thought this was an
opportunity for me to do some quick
research on public opinion toward just
the israeli-palestinian conflict
obviously events have gone beyond that
on so I'm going to talk about both the
israeli-palestinian conflict and in just
a little bit on Libya and I want to do
this in the context of research I've
been doing on partisan conflict and
public opinion in the united states
including work that I've been doing with
my colleague y le block elkin
coincidentally at bar-ilan university
also it's actually a great pleasure for
me to speak on this topic with eitan
Gilboa chairing the panel since his
early work on this greatly influenced
the writing that I did on the subject
and he hasn't some new work coming out
on this so I look forward to hearing his
comments in addition to yours as well
can I want to keep this short there are
three things I think we should watch
closely when it comes to American public
opinion toward the israeli-palestinian
conflict first now the summation that
surprise you give it given everything
else happening now the
israeli-palestinian conflict itself is
not very high on the public's radar
screen as a highly salient issue for the
American public now this can change by
tomorrow of course but this is
significant and perhaps unusual even
with the ladies even with the latest
incidents in Israel and as there's a lot
of competition for news media airspace
second is what I think of what I think
of as the American public's what I call
strong predispositions if not firm
opinions toward the Israeli and toward
the Israelis in the Palestinians and the
idea of a Palestinian state now I focus
and refer to American public opinion
based on readings from American national
public opinion polls in particular there
are three kinds of opinions and
attitudes that I've tracked and I want
to comment on one is responses to a
survey question poll pollsters have long
ask now for decades regarding whether
the American public sympathy
are with the Israelis or the Palestinian
so question a question about kind of gut
emotion now when I wrote about this 20
20 odd years ago these sympathies ran
not surprisingly for 21 in Israel's
favor with a fair number of people
saying not sure don't know work or the
head sympathies for both or 44 neither
and this result back then was fairly
stable stable though it looked to me
from just my political interpretive
perspective that I thought that over
time public opinion would shift that
least somewhat in the direction of more
sympathy for the Palestinians so that
the public would become more divided
with regard that you've Israelis in the
Palestinians what did I find when I
looked at all the data I was strikingly
wrong in reviewing the data since then
I've been very surprised to see that
this this forward 14 to 1 ratio has
hardly changed at all the latest Gallup
poll numbers that I could find on this
and they're actually from last month
februari which is kind of miraculous
since the pollsters asked about kind of
you know burning issues and and and at
the time this wasn't wasn't so burning
and it's only an artifact of the fact
that galloped makes it a point to ask
this question every year and it was time
to ask the question I guess the results
were the split was sixty-three percent
sympathy toward Israelis fifteen percent
toward Palestinians so the split was at
least four to one again and this time
the sixty-three percent is actually to
my knowledge and a time can correct me
if he's found differently it's the
highest percentage ever that Gallup
reported and it's a it's due to the fact
that fewer people say not sure that as
people have opinions about this quite
fully why is this ratio been not been
stable well one reason in my judgment is
that the narrative of the the reality in
the region that that's involved on and
off cycles of Hamas and Hezbollah
terrorist and other attacks and in
Israeli responses and so forth and kind
of a continuing cycle of that has kind
of maintained that that ratio the other
main reason almost certainly and I guess
it's obvious to you maybe less so to me
until I thought about it has to do with
911 and the American the conflict
between the United States and radical
Islam in contrast there is no evidence
yet that anything Barack Obama or J
Street or Israel has said or done
including the killings on the Turkish
has shaken americans overall leanings
toward israel now there are two be sure
public opinion data that showed that the
public is critical of Israel when it
comes to specific incidents and issues
but the overall picture of public
support is I think more relevant now
when we look at the major issue of
Palestinian statehood what we find in
the public opinion data is that
Americans basically support at a
majority level independent independent
Palestinian state which will include
Gaza and the West Bank that said the
American public is largely very
pessimistic about the region there's
been a large and stable by a margin of
two to one two-thirds who don't think
that the Israelis and the Palestinians
will be able to live in peace the same
applies if the survey questions refer to
Arabs rather than Palestinians the third
point I want to make about American
public opinion is that there's one crack
in it now there was this old saying that
that partisan politics you know stops at
the water's edge and there have been
recent debates about whether Obama and
Drake Jay Street have politicized the
issue in a partisan way the crack is the
possibility that partisan conflict now
bipartisan conflict I mean differences
between Republicans and Democrats at the
elite level put at the political
leadership level and political and
public and partisanship at the mass
level may have changed in striking waste
now what's happened historically in the
United States and there's a long
literature a long story about this but
it may come as surprise to some of you
or maybe no surprise to others of you
were most of you that since the 1970s
American politics has become much more
partisan and much more what i would call
ideologically partisan that is political
leaders now Republican leaders are more
consistently conservative on a wide
range of issues Democrats are more
consistently liberal the Republican
Party is a more consistently
ideologically coherent conservative
parties the Democrats as well maybe it
may be a little bit less coherent and by
me but I mean by ideological
partisanship I mean to be a Republican
now means to be conservative on economic
welfare issues racial issues social
social cultural values issues the via
Democrat means being liberal on those
kinds of issues clear differences on
regulation the environment and so forth
more
emerging artisan differences with regard
to immigration George Bush's positive
views toward immigration and John
McCain's I think will become an
historical aberration shortly the one
big change that's occurred is that this
kind of ideological partisanship is
begun to occur on foreign policy issues
in a very clear way and the best
evidence for this is comparing public
opinion to help comparing the positions
of party leaders and then also public
opinion data that is these partisan
differences have now penetrated to the
level of mass public opinion people who
self-identify as Democrats and
Republicans or more basically you know
more liberal and conservative
respectively on a wide range of issues
and now this applies to foreign policy
issues whereas where the Republican
position is a position toward basically
unilateral more likely militarism rather
than not where the Democrats take on
more multilateral positions now that's
penetrated and that also is we find that
at the elite level is most clear during
the Bush administration and we now find
that that's this is penetrated to the
level of mass public most strikingly
when we compare public opinion data
before 911 and after 911 as this has
been tracked over time and this is some
of the work that I've been doing so big
the big question for me is is that has
this penetrated to basically American
politics with respect to American
politics toward the Israelis and the
Palestinians now and especially now I
mean the common wisdom seems to be now
that a partisan differences occur it's
because of Barack Obama and J Street and
maybe things the Israelis have done or
not done well in a 1997 pew research
center poll and this is the only data
that i could find relevant for the
comparison with regard to sympathise
toward the palestinians and israel's in
Israelis 55 the partisan differences is
really very small it's only about a
seven-point difference now just to give
you a perspective partisan differences
in attitudes toward president the police
support for the president popularity the
popularity ratings of george w bush and
barack obama the partisan differences
there were 70 percentage points that is
these are these are really at an
all-time high the seven percent
percentage point difference in 99 in
1997 was with small potatoes fast
forward to the first poll that I could
find after September 11
october two thousand one that difference
basically widened to sixteen percentage
points and the latest poll i could find
partisan splits on was april 2010 where
a Pew Center poll found a 20 percentage
point difference so this partisan split
has occurred this partisan split has
occurred not because of anything because
the basically present Democratic
leadership is done but but what's
basically evolved over the past this
partisan split is perhaps more
noticeable on the Palestinian state
issue and there there's a 20 percentage
point difference as well based on a may
2009 gallup poll where among democrats
56% supported a palestinian state
whereas among republicans only
thirty-nine percent supported it with
forty three percent opposing and
actually surprised me quite a bit so
there's a potential for further partisan
conflict here but these partisan
differences are much smaller as i said
then partisan differences toward other
issues and toward the president toward
the American president the big question
of course is can the israeli-palestinian
conflict become a more divisive partisan
issue I think public opinion is likely
likely to be a constraint on political
leaders in this regard unless events in
Israel and Gaza and the West Bank
changed the dynamics of the conflict and
the narrative about it changes in a
major major way now we can only
speculate about this it would also
require of course that Democratic and
Republican leaders split coherently on
this which does not seem to be likely at
the moment which takes us to the the
Arab Spring what is most striking about
American public opinion toward us action
in Libya is not just that there is clear
support for it especially a very strong
support when it's framed in terms of
protecting civilians from Qadhafi's
forces in that case seventy percent of
the american public supports the current
air attacks in the no-fly zone further
and this is the most stunning thing
there is ZERO partisan difference that
is seventy percent republican seventy
percent of denmark
that's basically take that to that
position why is that the case well the
clearly it's clearly the case because
Republican within the Republican Party
in conservative circles and within
liberal circles and democratic circles
the leadership is split that is the
Republicans who come out on both sides
of the issue they're Democrats that come
out on both on both sides of the issue
and in this case case either the public
is taking cues from their favorite
partisan leaders or they're saying you
know the heck with that let me just look
at what's going on and what's going on
is is basically the image and narrative
that they get from the media which is
which at this point is all it seems to
be all mostly all gung-ho and supportive
of the of the of the air attacks well
will this change the this depends on two
things one is it depends on
circumstances on the ground in Libya and
elsewhere and it also depends on where
the political leader leadership comes
out on the issue at this moment it's not
fully clear maybe we'll find out a
little bit more tonight thank you very
much mr. Shapiro I've just completed the
study of American attributes to Israel
and the herb Israeli conflict from 2002
2010 my findings and interpretations
very similar to what you have heard we
will now open the form for questions and
answers just please mention your name
and the person you would like to answer
your question please yes Ronald helmets
to the panel general I think the
question about belief systems and
ideology and attitudes are very
important but I did want to however ask
given the moment that we renounced the
Spring revolutions to think
institutionally a little bit regarding
the executive branch and its relation to
the legislative branch as these as
political engineering has to go forward
so you have a parliamentary system in
Israel you have a presidential system in
the United States you have
in developing countries you had a lot of
summer presidential some of
parliamentary so how is political
scientists do you see this question
about in searching for sustainable
democracies in the Arab world this
question about presidential ism versus a
parliamentary system and can the Israeli
experience be instructive to their
neighbors regarding presidential and
parliamentary the second question is all
less relevant to Israel and having to do
with federated systems versus unitary
systems because decisions are going to
have to be made regarding whether or not
we're going to have a decentralized
versus highly centralized the unitary
States the Iraqis obviously are been
part of this process already there ahead
of this they may be instructive for the
do's and don'ts so my question is there
with really institutionalization of
democracy another question farber pearl
I I think it would be generally accepted
that most countries have strong
religious affiliations of one kind or
another and I was very struck
particularly this morning there seemed
to be a great fear of the Muslim
Brotherhood and I just like to hear a
little more about people's thoughts and
feelings about Islam expressing itself
politically particularly I would be
interested i guess and professor jamal
and professor Feldman's thoughts on that
thank you very much last question in
this round my name is Peter Seto I
wanted to ask professor Jamal and
Feldman if it's fair if you share my
view that there's a striking lack of
imagination and energy which is not
typical of Israeli society in the
diplomatic efforts the NGO efforts the
people-to-people efforts to reach out to
Arab audiences who are very relevant to
the outcome of Israel's enterprise
it was only when I was in the Peace
Corps in chat in 1980 that I discovered
there had been an Israeli agricultural
mission to Chad to as an extension of
some of the skills that they developed
in agriculture it ended I don't know
what happened to it that kind of effort
it strikes me took for granted or had
had the lack of that kind of evidence
taken for granted the Arab public
opinion which is so important to the
future of the Viet of the enterprise
thank you thank you um I'm not sure on
the first question I'm not sure what
lessons Israel has to offer between
parliamentary and presidential systems I
mean after all again this is one of
those issues that Israelis constantly
debate and they're not terribly happy
with the system they have they
constantly are searching for and
sometimes they're even playing around
with the possibility or testing other
systems like the two elections we held
in the late 90s ah that where we change
the system and have the direct elections
of a prime minister and that was such a
spectacular success that after two
elections we went back to the previous
system and if Arabs want to experience
are completely complete proportional
elections welcome I it's i'm not sure
what they you know what the what the
outcome of that would be on the issue of
political Islam and the question is of
course which political Islam and where
there is a huge debate and I think that
that that doesn't come to you as a
surprise that that debate is also taking
place although to some extent lesser
maybe in Israel than in other quarters
ah as to whether for example what's and
and and the evidence is there is a mixed
evidence for example regarding the
argument that some people are making I
know that they were referred to in so
somewhat derogative
returns in the first or second panel
that are arguing that these the Muslim
brothers in Egypt are becoming moderate
or pragmatic I'm not at all sure that
they are becoming moderate or pragmatic
but one cannot ignore the evidence that
they have conducted themselves at least
in these months remarkably pragmatic
remarkably programmatic now then of
course that begs the question is this
tactics or is the strategies that a
temporary change or a fundamental change
is the akp in Turkey the model or not
and then there's that doesn't resolve
the debate because their people were
debating where the AKP itself is going
so so these issues are hotly debated the
third point about the issue of emergent
of imagination and I call it creativity
I also think that that is tied to
something that I did say it's an
analytical observation as to where we
are and I'm talking about where we are
on the Israeli side of this issue I
actually think that as I said I think
that Israel right now is experiencing a
period of of paralysis at the top and
and I think that that also percolates
down on the level of creativity I think
that there are some areas where Israelis
the Israeli system continues to be very
creative especially on the issue of
prevention of the worst consequences but
whether it today remains as proactive as
creative as it was for example in the
1960s when Israel had an extraordinarily
extraordinary sophisticated diplomacy of
forging alliances with the minorities in
the region with the maronites in Lebanon
and the South Sudanese and the Kurds in
in Iraq and and with the periphery with
turkey and the Shah of Iran and so on
and so forth and these development
projects that the Israelis later in
African countries undergo
damir our prime ministership and before
that underscore you know do we have that
creativity now in the Israeli system
unfortunately i'm not sure that we have
the same kind of creativity today that
on the positive side that we there
israel experienced in decades in the in
the past thank you please thank you so
much so i'll try to tackle those three
questions as they were asked on the
institutionalization i think that's a
really good question i mean what i mean
Egypt is going to be basically a
combination of presidential ism and
Parliament and a parliamentary system I
think in many ways actually in terms of
diffusion or creativity whatnot of the
Israeli proportionate models one that
everybody at least the citizen level
would like to emulate because it's seen
as the most widely democratic although
probably this creates some of its own
headaches but people do see that as a
very open type of society where all
different flavors are represented and
you see these debates in the Arab world
as well so that's so it's still not not
clear exactly what's going to happen in
terms of how the institutionalization
will evolve but what we do know is that
it's going to be some combination of
presidential ism and parliamentary rule
the the issue of the Muslim Brotherhood
I think is also an interesting one and I
think there's two issues going on here
in addition to what should I just said
about the pragmatics or the tactics of
the Muslim Brotherhood I think we need
to be very careful here on the one hand
we hypothesize a lot about what will a
future Middle East look like with now
Islamists influencing policy the truth
of the matter is we've never really had
though a Middle East where Islamists
have been welcome to participate in the
political process without being
saboteurs or the opposition movement
that is blocked from participation so a
lot of our hypothesis are cautioned our
alarmist tendencies basically our that
in 1991 the feast we're about to access
power and they were denied that
opportunity Hamas has not had the
opportunity and I'm not supporting or
saying I'm not support the move
but they've been blocked from from
basically being held accountable as a
political authority of the Palestinian
people and and to represent and deal in
negotiations and dialogue with external
actors now the question is the
Brotherhood and so the question and if
we tend to basically shun the
Brotherhood from the political process
we need to ask ourselves the alternative
question what is the alternative you're
going to push them back underground and
we already know that the factors that
have radicalized these movements or push
them to the radicalization tendency are
the same factors that are going to block
them from power so this is this is the
dilemma right and so there's this
assumption or this operating hypothesis
but if we ignore the Islamist problem or
issue or whatever it's going to go away
it hasn't it's a bigger problem today
than it was ten years ago and if you
continue to apply policies that are
going to deny them representation you're
feeding into the problem I mean so so
this is that this is the big dilemma or
the 800-pound gorilla in the room and so
the question is you have to basically
look at the Islamist issue on its own
merits it has widespread support and we
need to ask ourselves why do people
support Islamism it's not like the
Middle East has radically become more
religious in the last decade right it's
not that the pockets of support for
Islamism right are among religious
people what we do know is that there are
few characteristics that that we could
argue shape Islamist support one when
there are no when there are economic
opportunities not afforded to the
population at large this alienates the
youth and the youth basically galvanized
them behind islamist discourse under
economic conditions you cannot talk
about democracy promotion or
institutionalization without having a
very very rigorous now economic
development package for Egypt I mean to
ignore that is going to be to ignore all
the problems of Egypt you have a
20-percent poverty problem you have
these huge income gaps in the region in
that in that country it's a disparity
it's almost like just basically almost
shameless to see it on the ground that
feeds into
it's on a critical ism second of all the
Muslim Brotherhood is not a monolithic
movement the Muslim Brotherhood is
basically as diverse as the Middle East
population is in itself you have an old
guard that happens to be more
conservative right-wing but you have a
new guard a younger generation of
Islamist who consider who call
themselves the liberal branch of the
Brotherhood they want to be engaged with
the United States they want to be
engaged with the not directly with the
Israelis and all of that I don't want to
paint this rosy picture but they say
they're willing to accept the peace
treaty that this is not their issue
their issues creating jobs creating a
better Egypt now if you deny the
movement in its entirety access to
political party you're going to be
pushing this liberal tied into the
right-wing camp so these are big
questions going on it doesn't help when
Hillary Clinton just visited the region
and the the liberal tightened the
Islamic Brotherhood wanted to meet with
Hillary Clinton and Hillary Clinton
refused to meet with them this does not
help the policies this does not soften
the image and does not win over people
in that in that effort and i also want
to talk there's this over overarching
theme in the questions if you may and
i'm not if i can just basically caution
against those this idea that whether the
type of institutions that emerge what
role will the muslim brotherhood play
that these demic this next phase post
spring revolutions can be micromanaged
or orchestrated right in it any people
are arguing that the the days of
micromanaging regimes and what the
nature of the opposition will look like
and who in the opposition will be able
to participate I mean these are multiple
enterprises that are you know you can't
orchestrate everything and it's just not
feasible to continue orchestrating these
processes and the lack of
democratization in the region I mean so
public opinion now is going to play much
more important role and so the idea is
in my opinion rather than think of
policies that might further radicalize
Islamists is to think of policies that
will win out constituents of the Islamic
movement
at least on the issues that you deem
most threatening to us geostrategic
interests so that's that's that's there
is there a question that I missed ok
I'll leave it at that sorry thank you
yes I mean I agree wish I that about the
mixture of presidential and
parliamentary system we saw the news
rail and didn't work and I would prefer
parliamentary system because they only
the anglo-saxon what we called
westminister models it works when you
have this mixture like here President
and Congress in Europe we know we is
more parliamentary system Francis its
own character but going there to the
Middle East I hope the professor's your
mother's right I I pray with her I'd say
don't make be prey to the same God may
be in different in different in
different modes I pray with her that she
should be right but I'm afraid again
maybe I'm still conservative in the
sense but when I look at Egypt I still
hope but among all of the different
fractions there even in the Islamic
Brotherhood the age of first as will win
because I'm still believe that if Egypt
will do what is good for Egypt that is
the best thing for the Middle East a
panera and we know that the pan Arabic
movement that not subtract to develop
was the most destructive and for the
Arabs for us for everybody and I think
if Muslims in Egypt thing was good for
Egypt and like
and others in other countries also think
what's good for their own and not the
start to develop some 10 Arab and Muslim
penny slow movement that would be the
most dangerous because this will bring
out also a position and there we have
the Shiites alighted division and all of
this will not promise to the many hopes
a nice when we talk about the i call it
the Arab Spring just hope is not going
to turn into an Arab something huge is
have seen other half days in the Middle
East the 50 hot days and which are very
not pleasant and I really mean it I
needed some hard that of course that if
there would be me know that ultimately
democracies are good Markus album like
more peace but the question is whether
as the hill of point out in the morning
whether young democracies have these
tendencies saw them on the way to
democracy it's very dangerous let me
just say one thing about the the NGO
issues that was just brought up here
look again let's put this way I was
always a liberal but I now make them
becoming more more conservative because
I really see for instance if how can
somebody today believe in NGOs when in
South Africa they come out and the only
thing they have better the NGOs are busy
with Israeli Human Rights when when you
have all over the world you have such
such regimes that that destroy their
citizens and durban all these NGOs come
together and all countries it bothers
them is ray ille so all these attempts
and I have these debates with with my
colleagues to develop all these
Democratic live
of engagements that we have and then we
tried and here I asking my friend and
chef choi Feldman look what what came
out of all these use of all these
diplomatic initiatives probably have
with the curtain with and with the more
maronites and with and with the even the
Raven there were some attempts with the
cops I think I don't think that was such
as such a great Democratic success to
all these attempts so I would prefer the
old realist model of everybody taking
care what is good for him and what's
good for his country and that I think
how we're going to get to some more
stable or Middle East buzzer shapiro on
on institutions one argument in favor of
a parliamentary system with endogenous
elections had a selection said that can
be called quickly is that it could
prevent a strong president from kind of
take trying to take over and change the
election rules and so forth thank you
next questions basically yes i would
like to say to our ask of shy a question
which is he spoke about paralysis in
israel and might not be better to call
it creative stasis that netanyahu is
taking small steps not well-publicized
taking down checkpoints the i heard that
the West Bank economy had a faster
growth rate than China last year may be
the fastest in the world helped by these
Israeli underground policies and in a
time of uncertainty might it not be
better to have this kind of creative
stasis obeah in my view with a little
more positive spinning publicity for it
but have that and then I want to ask
amount of Jamal don't we have
perfect examples of Islam assists
engaging politically in Iran on one hand
and turkey I'm sort of the other hand
Thank You professor / Jovi's please i
want to focus on the links between
public opinion and democracy and anyone
could try to handle this seems me two of
the crucial links are intensity of
public opinion of you on various routes
and elite perceptions of opinion in and
intensity so what do we know about that
you know for relevancy in the region and
specifically to pick on my colleague Bob
but others are free you're given you
know our normal and amount also given
our normal poll data how do we get a
hold of intensity of preferences thank
you next one please i shore joint
program GS and jts my question is more
specific I don't know you know in the
realm of what we're talking about but to
Professor Shapiro directly and more
broadly to the panel if they'd like to
comment in in terms of public opinion
I'd like to focus it more in on the
college campuses I mean I'm an
undergraduate student and for me we're
on it we're at Columbia University i
figured i'd ask the question in terms of
the israeli-palestinian conflict and how
we see it manifest itself on college
campuses today and public opinion across
North America to that and even in Europe
to an effect you see an increase an
increase in polarization I'm talking
about you know Israel apartheid week i'm
talking about these demonstrations and
protests on campus and the dichotomy i
can only speak from my position as in
within the pro is 0 movement here at
Columbia but um even today we had an
article in the Columbia spectator about
what's going on in terms of activism on
campuses and in terms of students I'd
like to hear what the commentary would
be I mean professor Jamal princeton
university tried to boycott Houmas i
mean i'd like to see what what you all
are thinking about that and how it plays
into the effect of public opinion across
the United States yes doesn't run home
without going to the extreme of asking
which American Jewish organization is
responsible for the demonstrations in
Libya Egypt and the rest I think it is a
bit strange that we haven't had a
question on the influence of the
pro-israel lobby in the United States
and the changes in the pro-israel lobby
so I throw it out to ever wishes to
respond try a brief response you don't
pick on me because of the last question
yes I see brief responses please in the
Middle East very brief questions have no
brief response actually the last one is
a big one i'm not sure that i have a
quick response to that i'd like to
respond to two questions the first one
is two touch moil sandler that because
some of the question came in connection
to what he said earlier and and he came
back to me on this issue of the periods
of israeli creativity and i'd like to
make I'd like to first of all say that I
think your bottom line about the fact
that when critical strategic cross cross
roads were reached oftentimes Israeli
leaders found the inner strength to make
the right decision and to ignore Ben
Gurion was definitely not a person that
was obsessed with public opinion polls
and he had the philosophy about this he
said leadership is about forging and
framing public opinion and not following
public opinion I didn't in didn't mean
to say say that what Israel did during
its period of creativity or periods of
creativity actually I think that most of
Israel's history most of the 60 years
plus were periods of creativity that
this is somehow connected to the issue
of the Democratic success or so on the
Alliance's that
were forged in the framework of this
creativity were raised on realist
considerations and they were
tremendously successful see the tool but
the point about this is that the test it
the test you you fret you for a
formulated is too easy you know if an
opportunity is in the face of an Israeli
leader does he make the right decision
or does he make the wrong decision two
of the three cases that you focused on
are not cases where the Israeli Prime
Minister faced an opportunity two of the
cases are cases where the Prime Minister
took an active role in creating the
opportunity okay beggins had a role in
the extent to which the Sadat initiative
became an opportunity it has to do with
his response to set out and Reuben
Reuben definitely was not faced with
Oslo he he had he had a role in in also
forging Oslo so the question then is you
know how many cases do we have of
situations where there was there was an
a potential a possibility and then the
question was then is Israel exercise and
doesn't exercise now the kind of
creativity that is required to test
whether there is a real opportunity or
there isn't a real opportunity now I
think that if you take back for examples
a prime ministership I think that Camp
David too is a big question mark III I
don't belong to the camp that places the
responsibility for the failure on the
hawk I think that the Ark in our effort
and Clinton and their teens there is
plenty of blame to share around for for
the failure of Camp David actually I
think that there was one case where I
believe and I think one of the speakers
in one of the panels in the morning
mentioned that where I think Barack did
face a real opportunity and that he was
deterred by his perception of what the
Israeli public would accept it not
accept and that is the Syrian issue i
think in Shepherdstown there was a deal
I accept the analysis of
number of Israelis who were there and
believed that there was a deal and Brock
as you know told Martin Indyk when he
landed I can't go for it and when he
said I can't go for it he meant because
of domestic reasons the second point is
the issue of out Netanyahu and I think
that Netanyahu deserves lots of brownie
points for his understanding and that's
not actually surprising that the 10
yahoo has a philosophy about the
importance of economics and I think that
in fact he he did what he had what he
had to do and he did it in a more
courageous way and he overruled some of
the hesitancy in some quarters of the
Israeli Defense community and saying we
have to give this a chance we have to
give the bottom up a chance and by
reducing checkpoints and roadblocks and
so on because you can't have economic
development in the territories without
issue addressing the issue of movement
and an access and so on and so forth but
and here's the big but the the the whole
bottom up project where is it worth well
whether it's the economic development
whether it's the institution building
side of it which is led by Salam Fayyad
whether it's the security side of it
which was led mostly by the Americans
general Dayton and some of the Europeans
and so on and so forth they are all
together they make for the very positive
changes in the West Bank none of this is
sustainable in the long run if the
bottom-up is not met by a breakthrough
at the top down because the bottom up
remains vulnerable to the Hamas
narrative that says this is only only
makes occupation more palatable the only
way to battle this narrative ultimately
in the end is a breakthrough at the top
down without that this whole wonderful
development of the last two two and a
half years is a house is a house of
cards
I'm on the intensity of preferences it
makes the most sense to talk about
intensity when the issues are salience
we may have to wait a little bit with
with that regard in terms of how to tell
you know which groups are more intense
obviously there are their sources other
than public opinion data but with regard
to public opinion data the things to
look at are you know if the surveys ask
people how strongly they feel about
their opinions but the other thing to
look at is with regard to these this
polarization that's occurring look to
see which which which side is moot is
moving the most in terms of the gap in
opinion separating and if you look and
the data that that I've talked about the
movement seems to be coming from from
kind of conservative Republicans and if
I had to point my finger to any group
with more intense opinions on the on the
right it would be the the kind of
Christian Right more so than the than
the tea party but and and those kinds of
things come into play big time in the
context of kind of intra-party
competition watch watch how the issue
plays out in the upcoming primary
elections for 2012 thank you come on
please thank you i'm gonna try to be
briefed on the netanyahu West Bank
economic development i'm just going to
echo what she I just said people on the
ground and on the Palestinian side
believe that things are getting better
economically there are more
opportunities and whatnot but again
where's this going it's not clear where
the end game is on this and so this is
creating vulnerability and it might
swing the other way so it's not just
suffice to get comfortable because
things are looking a bit rosier right
now I mean also on the Palestinian side
of things there is an understanding that
the this this fresh air of economic
development reduce checkpoints is also
coming with a much more I don't say much
more but at least a heavier hand of the
Palestinian National Authority in terms
of how it's wearing day to day things
quickly on the Islamism Iran versus AKP
that your point is right on target I
can't find the person asked a question
but the ideas that's precisely the point
there is great variation within these
movements and there's great very people
will monopolize Islam for for for
radicalization but also to be a
mainstream movement and we need to think
of it that way we need to start asking
ourselves the empirical question under
what conditions are Islamists able to
maintain this moderate middle of the way
type of political organization on the
issue of college campuses that's an
important question I just want to say as
somebody who's seen this for several
several several years of my career that
I've always first of all the
polarization on us campuses is even
worse than polarization we see in Israel
Palestine be as long as people are
catching these debates along the moral
right issue you will always be a be a
polarized communities i mean the the
things that unite these movements in
terms of their their viewpoints looking
forward are so much more than the things
that divide them and I know it's easier
for me to lecture from here where I sit
but I hope all student leaders can hear
this and work around creating common
understanding common commonalities
around these issues than just enhancing
the polarization the pro-israel lobby
quite honestly don't mean we've heard
very little about the influence of the
pro-israel lobby and these and these
revolutions so that's probably a good
news and can't be everywhere so that's
probably good news and I'll leave it at
that okay unfortunately we're running
out of time one minute one thing how
much more creative can you be when
Barack wanted to divide they were
thinking you've been dividing the
mountain you know instead they didn't
know how to divide it what the Temple
Mount the very dividing it slices one
should be belong to one religion one
should belong to the other religion they
were going as far as dividing day the
whole I don't know how many people know
it but the whole Old City's about in
terms it's one square kilometer in that
square kilometer they were going as far
as dividing the streets we still on to
the Arab side with strong business who
belong to the Israeli side all nerd was
sitting hours with with Abu Mazen and
where did we where did it go and how far
can you be more creative Netanyahu was
it said here it's time to develop
something new from bottom up in terms of
economics I I wish him all the best but
I don't think that is going to work I
think that the main problem here and I'm
really thinking this is probably even
television diversity will agree that
that that that when it comes to the
right of return right chef munis is a
problem and chef munis is there area
with a big universities built this
belong this was the ancient there was
the old Arab name of Tel Aviv University
they want to forget it but but the bar
ilan is still built on a free land it
was not never belonged to nerves and
until the university still belong it was
talking about the right of return I mean
they were working how can you compromise
okay this did this debate this debate
cannot end here I just want to say that
we have heard diverse opinions but if
there's one message coming out on this
outstanding panel is caution we are very
good experts about the past very poor
forecasters and we will have to be very
careful
in predicting what will what will happen
both will be happening take a 10 minute
break at three-thirty we continue with a
policy makers round table